alors où l'achat local est si populaire
les vignerons du québec voient leur
arrivée en épicerie comme une occasion
extraordinaire de voir enfin leur
industrie prendre son envol dans un
champ d'honneur une juge de ligne
annonce tout nouveau les vins du québec
on va mettre dans vos une broche pour
n'est attaché la bouture la bouture est
tout jeune alors ici savez devil hills
have a dream à ceux des boutures de ving
christophe limoges et directeur du
domaine du ridge dans les cantons de
l'est
un des plus grands vignobles du québec
dans le fond une vous seront la plante
maintenant avec un rapport du raisin ça
va prendre un prêt 4 pour juger une à
quatre ans il va avoir une demande le
gouvernement du québec autorise enfin
des artisans à vendre leurs vins en
épicerie une véritable révolution pour
les producteurs d'ici ça a vraiment
commencé avec ios 4 1 avec la saq qui
ont décidé de créer la catégorie
origines québec puis de mettre en valeur
les produits locaux ont soutenu le
projet de loi 88 qui est arrivé jeu
savant lui paraît donc en deux mois en
décembre 2016
ça a été super parce que le vigneron
plus encore le démontrer à se regarder
juste l'exemple donné un exemple des
producteurs de la région de magog qui me
produisais du vin datiche gbagbo mellick
rien les consommateurs autour de magog
ne peut pas acheter le vin dans les
épiciers ou de sheitan et des panneaux
maintenant ils peuvent laisser qc il ya
juste un un match à celle à cuba peut
pas acheter les divins dont vous faites
10 20 peut pas acheter vos 10 20 amar
choisir un ou deux des fois même pas
alors les producteurs à la difficulté à
écouler leurs produits tandis qu'ali
peace river lipstick plus de flexibilité
donc clip six autres à gagner à faire
rentrer des produits locaux qui on le
vit que je pense avec les micros les
microbrasseries ils y ont vraiment
accorder une place à part pour nous les
vins du québec
ça vient compléter notre offre c'était
tout naturel pour lui autant d'efforts
pour pour les tenir un magasin il ya une
demande
la marque pour les vins du québec selon
nous redonner interne 30 % des vins
québécois qui ont été achetés chez nous
l'ont été par des gens qui n'achètent
pas autrement que 20 dans nos épiceries
donc tout de suite on va marquer
vraiment une demande pour sa balle on
commence à préparer la prochaine saison
accueil à des cultures et bout de soi
qui sont prélevés dans son déploiement
tu viens de nouvelles sommes
toutefois certains vignerons craignent
que les consommateurs perçoivent leur
vin comme des produits bas de gamme en
les rendant accessibles en épicerie et
un dépanneur et ont pas le choix c'est
la cuve pour les prendre donc il faut
qu'ils écoulent aux produits à quelques
pas mais c'est à eux à vendre un produit
de qualité à le faire connaître le faire
savoir
puis ça va améliorer un peu le choix est
aussi le consommateur qui et de quoi
peut-être qui est pas encore intéressés
l'indiqué pas encore assez ouvert pour
aller chercher des vins québécois faut
dire que ce sont des vins tu fais des
cépages en général hybride
donc c'est un peu plus rustique comme
comme goût par rapport à ce qu'on est
habitué de voir donc tranquillement il
faut que quelques consommateurs
s'habituent à séoul le pire danger c'est
de refaire les mêmes erreurs qu'avec le
cidre québécois dans les années 70 on
s'est mis à produire industriellement du
cid bon ça marchait très fort pendant à
peu près deux à sa tombe et parce qu'il
y avait trop de mauvaises cidre c'était
vraiment de mauvaise qualité
alors bon ça a pris du temps vaincre
incident remonte c'est vraiment à
plaindre les vents de sud au québec
alors j'espère que ça soit pas la même
chose avec les mains québécois il reste
que la majorité des vignerons québécois
sont des petits producteurs qui n'ont
pas le volume nécessaire pour vendre à
la saq
en étant présent sur les étalages de
certaines épiceries tout au long de
l'année ils pourront assurer leur
croissance et offrir des vins à des prix
compétitifs
ça va donner vous a donc entrepris à des
entrepreneurs de se lancer dans le
domaine des vignes pas que je dirais
dans les prochaines années ça va
concocter de bons ce qui se fait à
niagara ou ailleurs en ontario
il va en plus de vignerons et doit en
train de vous êtes victime de votre
succès webster go prime puis en plus on
le voit avec le changement climatique
maintenant l'ectrims en est à wafa bord
du québec pour développer du bon vin et
puis le savoir enfin aussi va se
développer
[Musique]